let me ask you first Marv did you watch
mayweather vs mcgregor yes Chris I did
did not expect much particularly when
you get that type of wacky you know
promotional tour and my first impression
when they got into the ring I'm saying
to myself he McGregor looks bigger and
stronger than Mayweather and had a
tremendous reach advantage at a lefty
giving you different angles can be
tricky and then you think also Oh
Mayweather is 40 years old like talking
with Teddy Atlas at hearing Teddy's
opinions you know emphasizing that he's
40 and had fought in two years but I
think this is going to be a joke and it
turned out to be one of the more
compelling and action-packed fights in
some time the the four kings of the
1980s leonard Hagler duran and Hearns
guys that at one point did fight at 1:47
put mayweather in that mix where would
you rank him let's see you know I think
that sometimes your mind plays tricks on
you and you may go for the more exciting
fighter and Mayweather for the most part
despite his greatness and if you ask me
who would you rather see he would not be
on the top of that list as to who I
would rather watch I mean he was
brilliant and his defensive work but
what we saw the other night and not to
compare Mayweather against McGregor to
say Leonard and Hearns
and I was part of the pay-per-view team
that night doing that fight and I'll
never forget the fact that Leonard
actually changed up his styles got very
similar one Mayweather did asked around
for the other night because he was in
trouble and I'll never forget Angelo
Dundee in the corner just screaming at
Leonard and you know just getting him to
to get going and he
actually had Hearns a style and Hearns
was really fighting leonard style and
then Leonard you know came up with
victory you know by knocking down her
and that was pretty amazing but those
were two of the greatest fighters ovale
certainly of all time so for sure
excitement I would go with those guys
but Mayweather has to go down as you
know one of the extraordinary fighters
of all time for the most part strictly
from the defensive point view but hey
that's what you have to do talking to
Marv Albert NBN TNT joining me here on
the Dan Patrick show Marv the first time
you saw a dream team together what did
you think I got the chills when I first
saw them we did NBC at the time did the
tournament of Americans because they had
to qualify they had lost an 88 and so
they had to go through the tournament
was played in Portland and just the
first time they stepped onto the court
it was unbelievable to see that group
you know you look at is Michael Jordan
and Magic Johnson and Larry Bird and
Charles Barkley and Karl Malone and
right down the line you know David
Robinson Patrick Ewing to me it was a
greatest team in the history of the
greatest group in the history of team
sports ever assembled
I mean if everybody played today in that
type of competition and that means you
know having LeBron play and all the top
stars curry you know they they didn't
play in the Olympics as you know unreal
you could probably put together as close
to the dream team but it would not be
what this group was it'd be pretty close
which they never matched you know in the
Olympics after that but this this team
also was playing against international
teams that were not what they are today
I mean many of the international teams
as you saw the Olympics we you know to
give a run
to an NBA team because there's so many
NBA players it's so different and what
that particular Olympic tournament did
was encourage all the the basketball
strength in Europe and you know
throughout the world because people were
just fascinated with them they were like
the Beatles when they when they traveled
I mean just was fortunate enough to be
around them and they had top security
and couldn't even get on a bus without
thousands of people greeting them
outside the the hotel it became such a
big deal and I think the players
themselves were surprised about that and
really didn't go out much except from
for Charles Barkley who just you know he
just loves to talk to people and every
night he'd be walking down Las Ramblas
and Barcelona and just drawing crowds
and talking to everybody but that was a
team that Chuck Daly never called a
timeout throughout the whole Olympics
and they never trailed they had one
difficult once they did you know they
were gonna win but they they did have a
run in the gold medal game against
Croatia that I know envies well NBC's
carrying the entire tournament
and it opens with the Angola game in
which Berkeley threw that elbow which I
always thought was not as emphatic as
when you look at it because the rules in
the NBA led we're a little different in
terms of physical play and I you know
was unusual to see that in the Olympics
particularly right at the start but III
didn't even the Angolan players didn't
think it was that bad it's something
that I think has grown over the years
become legendary that Barkley threw an
elbow and the player from Angola but I
well people can see themselves tonight
before I let you go marbie legacy of
that team to me is that the world saw
that team embraced basketball and within
ten years really caught up you know the
USA team in o2 they got beat finished
six
in those World Championships you look at
the 92 team in its legacy what would you
say it is I would say that it changed
basketball because of the influence on
the International game everyone you
think how many international players are
in the NBA today it's somewhere over a
hundred and twenty five and they're
outstanding you know not all but I mean
you have stars within that group and you
know originally FIBA had been advocating
making the switch to professionals they
did it for years and originally the NBA
was not enthusiastic about it in fact
the US and Russia have voted against it
no one expected that you know they'd
become this cultural phenomenon and it's
something that they were convinced to do
and it turned out to be you know
something that became very very
successful but what I want to remember
most about it also it was really a lot
of goodwill because I remember a game
and the team was practicing in
Montecarlo at the start and I can recall
there was a guard for the French team
going at Michael Jordan he's probably
about five foot nine and he was pushing
him around and taunting him and Jordan
was really getting annoyed and as you
know you know he didn't need much for
motivation and here's this guy even
though the US was was really up by a big
score against France this guy was all
over him and they're screaming at each
other then the game ends and the United
States went by a large margin the guy
comes over with his own photographer
puts his arm around Jordan and asked for
a picture and they took a picture photo
right after that and that was that kind
of set the tone after games at the
Olympics the players would take photos
with the US team which was a lot always
I got a kick out of saying that well
dream team that was good there was good
will spread all so let's let's say
despite the fact that most of the games
were were blowouts well dream team week
begins tonight the Olympic Channel home
of Team USA all
original broadcast on eight consecutive
nights in primetime Marv Albert on the
call for those games beginning tonight
8:30 p.m. Eastern Time ARP as always
thanks for joining here on the show hey
Chris the pleasure of anytime
that's Marv Albert NBN TNT part of the
92 Olympics broadcast team of course
back again in 2016 in Rio for the
broadcast of those Olympics the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience